the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit open courseware at ocw.mit.edu
good afternoon
congratulations for braving it through
what's now become a weekly snow disaster
this week's maybe three of them or
something
my name is john gabrielli this is
introductory to psychology 900 this is a
course about you
okay the entire course is uh
what do we understand in a scientific
way about human nature how people's
minds work how people's brains work that
supports their mind this entire course
is about what's a scientific way to
understanding how people feel think and
act in the world
and so it's a we're going to try to say
that we constantly think you must in
your everyday life think about you know
why do you have your preferences your
desires your what's easy for you what's
hard for you what's delightful for you
uh
why do other people behave the way they
do how do they think how do they feel
and so uh there's a lot of realms of
this that are tough to get to by science
but what we're going to focus on this
semester is you know where's the
scientific approach that shed light you
know in the way that we're used to
thinking about experiments and evidence
about how humans tick
um
and as we go through this semester we'll
talk about the brain
we'll talk a fair bit about uh chapters
from this book the man who mistook his
wife for a hat from oliver sacks it was
a bestseller you know even even when it
wasn't a sign for a course it's a great
book you'll enjoy it
short really fun chapters
we'll talk about how we perceive the
world how we see especially a little bit
how we hear how we think how we feel
personality how we differ from one to
the other what we sort of like and how
we behave in the world
development from childhood and infancy
through adolescence through young
adulthood where you are mostly um
through through getting older uh where i
am
social interaction how we behave in
groups and think about other people
uh and variation in in mental health or
psychopathology uh and increasingly we
understand that there's a huge number of
people who at some moment in their life
or another uh a struggle with some
aspect of mental health
and then we'll focus a lot on not only
the psychological aspects of that uh
what we said in terms of behavior but
also the brain basis of that and think a
little bit about to what extent uh the
mind is what the brain does to what
extent the mind is what the brain does
and so for every dimension of being a
human being that we'll talk about we'll
also talk about what we understand
currently uh from the neurological and
neuroscientific literature about how the
human brain supports and contributes to
different aspects of being a person
okay
so uh you know every every everybody
who's a sort of a works a certain field
thinks that their field is really really
really special right so here's why
psychology is really really really
special so it's really really special i
think most of all
because every endeavor that we undertake
uh at a university or or in society as a
whole
it's about people right except for when
we think about the rest of nature but uh
uh you know people study biology
chemistry and physics and uh they think
right that the uh the sun orbits the
earth for some period of time and then
they think it's the other way around
currently right okay so people come up
with these conclusions even though we're
trying to understand nature it's people
who uh make certain investments in
economics or behave in a certain way or
vote in a certain way it's people who
make music and appreciate music make art
and appreciate art
read and write literature right so in
all these dimensions uh there's
something very fundamental about what it
is about the human mind that gives birth
to these areas of inquiry uh and and and
how those areas domains of human
experience are enacted
so uh my only goal today is to try to
convince you in a number of different
ways
that uh we're not simple video camera uh
in our minds you know between our ears
recording the world in some objective
simple way that even the simplest most
obvious things are interpretations of
the world around us at many different
levels of thought and feeling and
perception and that our minds the way
our minds are constructed determines the
world that we experience that we see
that we act upon
and even very simple things that we
think are pretty objective and simple
right in front of our eyes are
determined by inferences and deductions
that our mind makes
weighing sources of evidence in the
world and coming to conclusions about
what's around us what we hear and what
we see
and how we think
so let's start with seeing if your
vision is reasonable uh you know we say
we you know if we see something we
believe it right um
so let's start with something very
simple uh these lines so one of the uh
tough things about psychology is ever
since the internet came into existence
people know every cool thing there is to
know right okay so i can tell you you
know when i began teaching like people
said oh my gosh i've never seen such a
thing it's unbelievable you know and
then now it's like two-thirds of the
club yeah i've got that you know my
computer at home and you know we did
that in like third grade or whatever so
uh so i'm saying is enjoy the ones you
haven't seen before don't ruin it for
your neighbors today because uh this is
it's harder and harder to surprise the
world in a nice way right okay but let's
look at these lines for a moment here
and perhaps you'll have the sense and
maybe is it glaring up there sir let's
see if this can do something
okay is that better okay
maybe not uh so you know you might have
the sense that this line
is a different length than this line and
this might be somewhere intermediate
right
now you know because of psychology it's
all a trick
but that's what's simpler than the
length of a line what's more objective
in some sense than the length of a line
but if we look at the actual lengths uh
they're all literally identical but that
center part looks different so what does
it mean for it to look different
it means our minds are determining as
simple i think as how long a line is
depending on the other information
surrounding it it's an interpretation in
context if we're simply looking the
lines will look the same
let's try another one
it's remarkable that those two lines are
identical in length
okay all right all right all right yeah
i can't okay i i just you know it's good
to test the limits of the credibility of
the audio right all right yeah of course
if our visual system were ludicrously
off would be constantly walking into
walls and you know falling out windows
and things like that right if we were
misestimating at that length so the idea
where we have visual illusions and i'll
show you some more that i think you'll
be impressed by
it's not that our visual system is
messed up or that psychologists think
it's hilarious to trick us
it's that lots of things our visual
system is brilliant at but it's
brilliant by having certain laws or
principles that it follows and we can
show that it's following those
principles by seeing that when we mess
with the typical circumstances those
principles calculate the wrong answer
so here's another one
so to most people uh which line looks
bigger the one in the middle or the one
on the side
i know you know it's all a trick right
okay but yeah this you know what could
be more obvious and this is longer it's
just a simple line but if we draw red
lines on top of it and move them over
here they're dead identical
the central circle does one of them the
middle circle look larger than the other
now you already know
intellectually that we'll turn out those
two circles in the middle will be the
same
but you have to convince yourself that
it still looks like they're different
here they are in red here they are next
to each other they're identical again
this is evidence that even for a simple
thing like the size of a circle your
mind is making inferences and there are
principles and laws that it's following
that determine what it is you think you
see
here's two monsters chasing each other
but in fact they're identical in size
the perspective cues make the
more distant one look much bigger
um this is from ted adelson this is a
beautiful uh uh demonstration of an
illusion um ted anderson says in
psychology department
uh there's there's a letter a here
and believe it or not there's a letter b
there let's see if this looks any better
when it goes like this
it doesn't
all right so you know one of the
important things about illusions
demonstrations in this class and you
will learn this as we go along is that
occasionally they fail then we come back
and discover what the lesson of that is
so uh it's i'm just telling you to show
you my monitor much brighter and it
always has before um
we'll adjust that
so i'm going to skip this but i'll show
you another time because it's so good
that i'm going to feel bad about this
okay
well let's see
this will work better
all the same shade of gray right
[Music]
did that work reasonably from where you
sat
okay
we'll try a few more
maybe
for some reason my connection is always
like this sorry
cool
[Music]
does that one look lighter than that one
that way yeah
[Music]
now they look radically different right
it's the same gray constantly but again
the context is hugely determining
how bright you see that gray there it is
[Music]
[Music]
two
boxes equal gray
[Music]
so things as simple as how bright
something is or how how long something
is um
you know depend on interpretation here's
a here's an illusion from uh
roger shepard
it's kind of great so here's two kind of
different looking tables right
but they're not that different and watch
there goes one table top
you're not impressed
that those are identical tables
okay i'm going to do it again
that's the identical tabletop
to me the one on the left looks pretty
rectangular and the one on the right
looks pretty squarish
no you're not easy to impress sir
[Laughter]
you see that those two bars are moving
uh together at the same time does it
look like they're like step little steps
but it'll show you
all right fine okay
[Laughter]
it's just like that but now you add
those bars does it look like little
steps
one more of this kind
this is kind of fun well
you see that the way that face the mask
is turning
it always looks like it's towards you
even though you know on one of the
rotations it's because of the way you're
interpreting the light is influencing
where how are you interpreting what's
okay
so
that's simply a consequence as far as
people understand that that
the source of the illumination is not
what you're used to so you're
misinterpreting
where the illumination is coming from
for the depth of the face what's front
and what's back whether the nose is
sticking in or sticking out
um
okay
okay
so um
so again the point in these illusions is
even for very simple things our minds
make certain assumptions about how we
interpret the world uh and that drives
everything uh that we see and how we act
upon that we see
so at a slightly sort of higher or more
conceptual level i need your help now
there's lots of these things that we'll
do this semester where you get to
participate i mean the fun thing about
you know i said this course is about you
when you could have thought that was a
bit rhetorical it's not it's truly about
you
so
so you get to be your own laboratory we
get to share a laboratory sitting here
and what i'm going to do is ask for you
to participate you don't have to do any
of these things sitting at your seat but
i think it's usually fun and
to do them so what's what's going to
happen is um i'm going to show you a
drawing
and uh let's let's
uh
look at
if
the people to my left so about in the
middle but you can decide for yourself
about this way let's have you be group a
if you're willing to be that way and ha
okay all right
all right because of that i can't call
you i was going to call you guys group b
but i already see that's getting me in
trouble so we'll call it group b but
that really means equals a but i'll just
call b okay all right so a and b
okay so what i need is group b
uh b for best a for awesome okay group
b group to kind of close your eyes for a
moment okay group b so if you're going
want to have fun with us close your eyes
for a moment group a you're going to see
some instructions and read them silently
to yourself
and then i'll ask you a question about
the picture
okay group a you're now reading group b
has your eyes closed so read read the
instructions silently to yourself
okay every now gr every group a close
your eyes everybody has your eyes closed
for a moment everybody has their eyes
closed now group b
look at your instructions so a has her
eyes closed b is is reading instructions
okay
okay everybody's eyes are open now
everybody's eyes are open and here's
your picture
sort of take it in i'm gonna ask you a
few questions about it look at it for a
moment inspect it okay here we go ready
so just out loud
was there an automobile in the picture
okay see this is a smart class we're
gonna have a all right
okay was there a man in the picture
was there a woman in the
picture okay
what this side again woman in the
picture
okay all right all right
okay a child
an animal
ah okay all right and now gets a little
uh uh it gets a little wild okay a whip
okay
a sword
all right a man's hat
a ball
a fish all right so there's this
agreement and that's you know it's it's
we're democracy right okay so you know
it's all these things are big setups
right so
uh here's what happened group a was at
was told they're gonna look at a picture
of a trained seal act
and group e got the identical
instructions but they were told you're
going to look at a costume ball so you
had a expectation of what you were going
to see that expectation drives your
interpretation of the very thing you see
next which is this picture
okay
all right
[Laughter]
okay is that all right
okay all right
and you know this is just for fun right
it's a setup you're participating nicely
you know but
you know in the world when groups that
are uh arguing with each other about
things like peace settlements
you know read a document or make a
statement
how much do you think the perspective
they start with
guides the interpretation of what they
read or what they hear right okay
because you didn't have big stakes in
this you weren't going i believe in fish
and if i don't see a fish you know
i know things aren't just and my group
will be not treated fairly right okay i
mean you're not emotionally invested in
and probably whether there was a fish
present um so uh you know your
interpretation your beliefs
guide tremendously what you think you
see and how you interpret the situation
for complicated things or even easy
things like lines or squares
and here's another kind of an example
where you would interpret you know that
is a b for baker or 13 if it's in
numbers again the context is driving a
lot of the interpretation
okay
now this is one of those examples uh
that
again when some number of years ago it
was a huge hit and now mostly people say
can't you come up with something better
that we haven't all seen on the internet
okay so uh don't if you know this don't
ruin it for the other individuals uh
and but what i need is uh a few
volunteers
um you'll be facing me this way who are
willing to
count
uh something and this mit we're pretty
good at counting
so what was the what's the message of
that the message is uh we've talked
about what we perceive what we see by
expectations and context but it's also
we have very limited what psychologists
call attentional resources we can pay
attention
to a limited number of things at a time
and even when those things can be right
in front of us if our attention is
focused or occupied by something else
like counting the passes and kind of a
difficult scene it wouldn't work
if it was if there was one or two passes
only because you you'll notice it but
when your mind is focused on identifying
all the passes among the players in the
white shirts they're moving they're
weaving with the other players and so on
um then
your attention is absorbed by that and
some of it is not left over to notice
what's right in front of you we'll talk
more about that but it's a huge thing
with humans uh that we can pay attention
pretty well on average to a thing at a
time under many circumstances and other
things escape us completely even if
they're obviously present if we were
looking at them or paying attention to
them
so um
here's another example of how our minds
make our world you know what we see and
what we don't see what we pay attention
to and what we don't pay attention to
and that's uh something to do with how
we hear
so
okay so i'm going to replay this
i think
so listen to what the guy is saying
and take a look and just tell me he's
going to say like he's saying some
letters okay just not a word
what is it
okay most people think he's saying da
okay
now let's try that again with i'm going
to turn off the sound
and i'm going to run the same film
what does his mouth look like it's
saying
gaga okay but now we'll do one more
thing which is um turn the sound back on
have you close your eyes and listen to
what he's saying
what's he saying
yeah so it doesn't work for everybody
every time
but the basic idea is most people think
they hear the word da coming from the
speaker
and in fact in their mind they do
because that's how they interpret what
they're hearing
but in reality the film clip is a film
clip of the person saying baa baa baa
and then an audio recording of the
person saying gaga your mind
intertwines across modalities what you
hear and what you see
integrates them in some way below the
level of consciousness you're not
thinking about it and you come up with a
different interpretation of what you
hear
right so
what you see would be is one thing what
you hear is another thing when your eyes
are open and your ears are open they
meld together and produce something a
third thing that's entirely differently
again your mind interpreting what you
hear
not your ear interpreting what you hear
in a simple sense
okay
how about things that we know
so let's think about this if somebody
were to ask you which is farther east
closer to the atlantic uh
san diego
california or reno nevada who likes san
diego as being farther east
a few hands who likes reno as being
farther east
okay
so
here's the mental map most people have
the mental map which is we know
california is right next to the ocean
right with arnold schwarzenegger
protecting us on that side of the
country right
and then nevada's a little bit more
towards uh toward towards boston right
okay that's a mental map that most
people have and that's how the hands
went up this is the actual map and the
only actual map you've ever seen ever on
a globe on a map anything because
california takes a big turn on the south
san diego is actually further east than
reno
why do we imagine and most people do
that reno is further uh east
when you've never seen a map or a globe
that's shown you that never ever ever
yeah
so the because it's farther from the
ocean because because in our mind we go
california is a way out there right
there's nothing you know hawaii is the
only one out there farther
eat west right so our mind makes us
answer despite that and that's what we
think we might think we might know now
we might not be totally certain we might
not bet the farm on that
which is farther north philadelphia
pennsylvania or rome italy so start to
think how would you think about that
it's not something you know i mean
nobody memorizes it right but uh how
would you begin to think which is
probably more northern
what's your first gut how many people
like philadelphia being more north
yeah how many people like rome being
more north oh there's kind of a mixture
of hands okay so the the answer is uh um
that rome is north of philadelphia
mostly people will answer the
philadelphia's north why they do that is
they think the u.s and europe they're
both sort of above the equator below
antarctica kind of aligned right even
sort of historically culturally uh so
they think well rome is pretty south in
europe and it is it's in italy
philadelphia is reasonably north in the
u.s it gets winters and all that kinds
of stuff so a northern city in the u.s
has got to be north
of a southern city in europe but in fact
europe is the whole continent has
shifted up compared to the us
so you won't wait to get your mind
around this which is further north
atlanta or chicago
all right okay
okay all right sir
yeah yeah that's that's awesome i mean
yeah so no this is
uh
because sometimes when you do this and
people go like wait a minute you know
all my assumptions are off like where am
i what's reality right okay
okay yeah
but here's one more uh two more uh which
is further north portland or toronto now
you are already learning the lesson go
opposite whatever i thought go opposite
right but why do you think most people
will answer uh the toronto's further
north
canada is up there u.s is below it but
in fact um that's the mental map and the
colors but in fact portland in oregon is
actually north
of toronto we'll do one last one which
is further west which is further west
miami florida which sits all the way you
know towards the atlantic ocean or
santiago chile which sits towards the
pacific ocean
further west so most people have a
mental map that north america and south
america are kind of lined up like that
and so you say well miami is farther
east and santiago is farther west but in
fact south america is fairly shifted
compared to north america and uh
santiago is actually
more eastern or miami is more western uh
one relative to the other right because
in our head we kind of think north and
south america they're kind of lined up
even though
we never saw a globe or map like that so
again you know kind of some of our
knowledge guides what how we think about
the world and what we believe we know
all right so what's the point of this
it used to be called telephone right uh
the story keeps changing in part
it's hard to remember details in the
story people remember kind of a nugget
or what we call a gist in psychology
just a little point and second um you
know what you take as a point is how you
then tell the next person right
the way you interpret the story of
something like that thanks very much
that was great
all right
again you know how you know
two things our memory for precise
details is surprisingly modest uh uh and
how we interpret things uh matters
changes things a lot
so now you had four brave students uh
demonstrating some of the limits and
properties of memory so now here's an
exercise you can do in your own seat
okay uh just you're just knowing
yourself how you did so uh but here we
go i'm gonna read you
some words
um and then just give you you don't have
to write anything down if you write it
down it's no good
uh and then i'm going to ask you
on a recognition test whether you heard
a word or not ready
so here's the list so just listen and
then i'll test your memory for it right
after
here's the list sour
candy
sugar
bitter
good
taste
tooth
nice
honey
soda chocolate heart
cake
tart
pie
okay
all right how many people heard the word
sour all right yeah excellent thank you
chair
candy hey
honey
building
suite
every hand up there you have a false
memory okay
now it's a setup okay because here's the
way they make these lists it's a setup
but there's a huge lesson and in fact
you may hear debates about what are real
memories what are false memories in
court cases in clinical cases
this is a laboratory experiment that's
been the
testing ground for lots of ideas about
how we make real memories and how we end
up with false memories so here's the way
they made the list they took the word
sour
and they took a lot of students
basically like you and said what's the
first word you think of that goes with
sour and people came up with this kind
of a list candy sugar bitter good taste
too nice honey soda chocolate heart cake
tart pie
but they left out one word that people
came up with a lot
the word sweet okay
so your mind interpreted the list you
said hey this is all about things like
that are related to sort of sweet things
sort of in one way or another sweet
sugar sweet candies you know sour sweet
and sour
honey is sweet chocolate is sweet right
so your mind
imagined it heard the word sweet uh and
the you know the majority of you put
your hand up that you actually heard the
word sweet your mind imagined it was
there because that was generally sort of
what was going on that was the gist of
the experience okay so uh this idea is
it's very easy because of the way memory
works we remember the gist of things
because that's what's the important part
it's hard to remember the details but
that just is an interpreted gist okay
the gist was it's sweet things so the
word sweet feels like it was part of the
memory and we'll come back to that later
on in the course
so um
one of the themes we'll talk about a lot
in the course is both an amazing power
of the human mind and an amazing apparel
of the human mind and is what
psychologists call automaticity is that
our mind in order to be efficient and
quick does things automatically without
thought without consciousness it lets us
walk without thinking a lot about where
our feet are it lets us speak quickly uh
without thinking about the syntax or the
vocabulary right it lets us do a lot of
things but the the the the that's the
power of it the peril is once something
becomes automatic we lose control of it
within ourselves
um
so i need somebody uh at their seat
who's willing to read aloud something as
fast as they can when they see it on the
computer monitor if i can get a
volunteer at your seats
okay all the way back there okay and
then i'll come to you for the second one
okay ready here comes uh as fast as you
can go
one way not do enter okay i know you got
you i couldn't trick you okay okay uh
but you might imagine a person might
mistake that right okay was there
another was it okay ready here we go go
yeah
okay because your mind is automatically
reading it's you know we have lots of
evidence in psychology that you're
barely looking at words like the you're
you're assuming over those things
they're they're almost invisible to
either they're even though they're
physically present because your mind is
looking for the big content right like
who cares about the word the right your
mind is going for the essential
information and it becomes literally
blind to what's in front of you because
it knows what it's looking for
here's a fun one you've seen things like
this before but it's always fun to try
it's the same principle
how many letter fs do you find in this
display
so can i get some numbers
four five six those are all good
we're not an exact science we're we
okay uh
okay
so some of you may have missed one or
two f's right okay again
it's because your mind your mind is
automatically you know people read a
spectacular typical readers read at
spectacular speeds and the way you read
a spectacular speed is you don't look
for little details you get the big words
and the big ideas and you zoom through
for the big meaning okay and you're
leaving behind what you consider to be
details yeah
ah
the question was if we asked a society
that
didn't pronounce f's or something like
that
meaning like a sound or something like
that does that matter for this yes and
it also matters a lot
that uh words like of our little
preposition words that we don't think
much about okay so yeah this is a setup
like finish you most people get or the
beginning of a word you're more likely
to get i think the pronunciation
probably matters i don't know that for
sure that's a very good thought uh and
certainly hiding it in words that seem
low in content for interpreting a
sentence is about the best way we did it
that's why the
the second the disappear too it's sort
of a low content word for processing a
sentence
um
okay this is an example what you know
but it's a nice example and we can come
back to it a couple of times
so let me think about
this for one second uh
maybe we'll do it this way that will ask
somebody at their seat who has typical
color vision if you're color blind this
one is not a good one for you okay i'm
just uh
some percentage are so um uh is somebody
willing at their seat to read aloud
stuff they see on a monitor
okay thank you um
so uh uh here we go so you're gonna see
uh words that are in printed in
different colors your job is to
read
name aloud
the color of the ink that it's printed
in that make sense so like on this f
you would say it's red on that f on the
is that okay here we go so start here
and just go
as fast as you can just keep going
great you're excellent okay same thing
read the color of the ink exactly like
you were doing go
green blue
you're pretty good all right
okay it's supposed to slow you down when
you get the colors the ink in the wrong
color and it usually does but you were
you were very good okay
all right
all right
again if you know this from you know of
course it's an internet don't ruin it
for others but think about it for
yourself so now we're going to turn to
thought there's 30 people in a room 30
people just think imagine you sat you
know there's groups of 30 here you get
the month and date of each person's
birthday so it's not the year they were
born but you know it could be december
1st or february 5th or something like
that what is the approximate probability
that two people will have the exact same
birthday
all right
i can tell you the vast majority of
people
under slightly less you know suspicious
circumstances than this will answer
about 10 percent
that's the vast majority
uh the correct answer is
okay
uh why do you think uh this is work from
conneman and tversky we'll come back to
this why do you think
people tend to answer 10 some 30 very
few people
give you the mathematically correct
answer of 70. why do they do that
because
they tend to think how often have i met
somebody who has my exact birthday
and you go not that often it's not like
it's like every 30 people i meet
somebody says you were born on you know
march 3rd i was born on march 3rd and
then you go have lunch and you go hey i
was born on march 3rd and then you go
have dinner with another group and they
go i was born in march there you go it's
not it's not something that happens a
lot right so you go well that in real
life it doesn't seem to happen very
often but what that's what we call a
heuristic a simple way to think about it
because your experience is kind of like
that but why is that incorrect
mathematically for this question
because the math depends on not
that it's exactly your birthday but any
pair of birthdays among the 30 people
and then it goes way up in fact it goes
to 70 percent
and if it's 24 people 50 if you're a
group of 36 people there's a 90 chance
just mathematically that two people will
share the same birth date okay
because when we face uh things that are
hard to think about because there's no
easy answer
humans tend to make take shortcuts and
go say what's the gist of my experience
and that's what i think the answer is
even when a calculable answer is
available it's human nature to make a
shortcut based on your sense of your
experience
so
uh
there's a very interesting line of work
dan gilbert at harvard is a leading
figure about this idea of thinking about
your future now thinking about our
future is a big thing right um we're
thinking about uh
you know what's it like in this course
what's it like in college what's our
friendship like relations with parents
what's our future career paths what kind
of life will we lead right our future is
something that's hugely on our mind i
mean i think very powerfully when you're
a college student or graduate student
what you know what's my future and a big
question that people have is what will
make me happy in a deep sense what will
make me happy in a deep sense because
that's the life i want to lead the
values i want to have the kind of career
choices and personal choices i want to
make
where i will devote my time uh on this
earth
so
most people
first of all tend to think about you
know good things right which is positive
things actually i can tell you we'll
come later in the course it's good to
think that lots of positive things are
happening it's kind of a nice place to
be in terms of being a happy person
um
but
it turns out uh that uh people have done
studies
like this so now this is particularly
sensitive for a faculty member but it
could work for any sports team you've
tried out or anything you've tried out
for in your life so what happens when we
get reviewed for tenure and you hear a
bit about that this is this was an easy
study first for a psychologist to do
what they did is they called up people
in the fall who were being reviewed for
tenure um and you know you get tenure or
you don't and it's a bit of a sad
process if you don't right because you
don't get tenure and then you don't feel
happy about that and you have to call
your parents and say i didn't get tenure
and your parents go come on if you just
slept better you would have gotten
tenure and you know
remember the piano lessons you didn't
take and you go all right so so so you
know it's a bit of a nuisance right on
top of that because weirdly in academics
we tend to be super specialized you have
to move out of town okay
you don't have to but typically then a
person who doesn't continue will get a
job somewhere else there's plenty of
stories of people who don't get tenure
at awesome places who are geniuses in
history okay the 10-year decisions are
often wrong but still you'd rather get
it than not you'd rather you know get
into a medical school than not you'd
rather make a sports team you want to be
on than not
um so here's what they found out if they
asked them uh what happens if you don't
get tenured with oh it's going to be
awful it's just going to be miserable
i'm going to be such an unhappy person
two years later
the average happiness of people who
didn't get tenure was equal to the
average happiness of people who did get
tenure okay
so okay you could say well 10-year only
professors care about tenure how about
winning the lottery okay you know what
if i want hundreds of thousands of
dollars there's been a lot of psychology
on this actually
in about a year to two the average
happiness of a lottery winner who wins
substantial amount of money is rated the
same by him or her as it was uh the
population as a whole yeah
yeah so this will come back to this but
i'll tell you so this is this is you can
like this or not like this okay so in
some parts of psychology we measure
things like reaction time to the
millisecond that's
you know good data right all right brain
activation that's good data when you ask
a person how happy they are the only
thing we can do is have you basically
fill a scale from one to seven how happy
are you okay and you could go well i'm a
little worried about that because you
know you know something like i hope that
makes you happy or something that you
know right so you could say how how much
can we trust subjective reports of
happiness and that's a very good
question on the other hand it's hard to
know what would be better than that
right it's we don't it's like if we
measure your pulse is that a better
measure of your happiness not you wanna
know
your pulse could be racing because
you're sad or happy scared or
enthusiastic so we don't have a better
one that we can think of but
psychologists do worry that sometimes
people will just say what they're
supposed to say or they'll pretend
they're happy or things like that we
have to worry about those things right
so you could worry deep down but a year
or two later people who win huge amounts
of money don't report themselves as any
happier than people around them
and kind of amazingly but i think it's
deep about life
accidents leading to quadriplegia or
paraplegia accidents that you know
before you had such an accident you
would imagine that it would be
something
extremely difficult and it can be in
many ways but by self-report uh
ratings of happiness return to typical
average populations of the same age in
about three months
so what's a huge lesson here
in happiness research a huge surprise is
two things
we're kind of bad at predicting what
will make us happy or sad which is kind
of weird right i mean we're kind of bad
at predicting it here's all these things
where we think you know they would make
us happy or make us not so happy it
turns out we're wrong once it's studied
at all scientifically
um
so we'll come back to that later on
because it's a very deep thing about
being a human is is what makes you happy
and and and your wrong guesses sometimes
about what does
so let me end with the last experiment
so we really haven't done experiments
until right now uh and this is now you
know a sensitive and difficult issue
which is uh
problems we have in dealing with racism
um and here's a here's a study that did
the following it said well in north
america certainly canada the u.s the
study was in canada
racism is widely condemned
as i think most of us
believe it should be
but examples of blatant racism still
occur in one recent poll said that about
a third of uh white individuals reported
hearing anti-black slurs in the
workplace in the last couple years okay
to pick one thing so how does this
happen in a society that speaks so much
about
not being racist about treating
everybody equally and fairly and kindly
how does it happen that we still
struggle that's a deep
difficult question about human nature
and the world we live in uh but here's
something again about this that's a hint
about why it's hard to get society to
change some of its behaviors
so here's the experiment okay it's an
actual experiment so they took two
groups of college undergraduates
and randomly assigned one to be in the
forecaster group that's a group that
tells you how they think they would feel
and how they think they would act under
a certain circumstance
and then an experiencer group
that's a group who actually undergoes an
experience and i'll tell you what that
is now
so in the experiencer group pretend you
are the research participant you walk
into a room
and you see in that room a black male
and a white male now those two are what
uh psychologists for some reason have
called confederates those are role
players they know what they're doing
okay they're not they're not they have a
plan of what they're going to do they're
going to put on a little show for you
but you don't know that okay
um and the black male stands up and
leaves the room to get his cell phone
and he gently bumps the white male's
knee this is all set up okay you're just
sitting there and you see that little
bump
and now there's three different groups
one group that's it nothing else happens
a small bump and the person leaves a
second group
as you sit there
the black individual lease room and the
white individual says quote typical i
hate it when black people do that it's
meant to be obviously provocative and
racist
and then what they consider an extreme
slur
the white person in the room playing
this role says uses you know the
derogatory word uh that's meant to be an
extreme slur
so
there's one more thing you need to know
now you're sitting there and you're
either in the control group or just been
the slight bump
or there's been a moderate slur or
extreme slur in their words the black
male returns don't forget he's in on it
and so is that white male but you're not
in on it you just think there was a bump
and something else may happen depending
on which condition you're in
and the experimenter then gives you a
survey about how you feel right now
sort of like the happiness but it's not
that it's like how do you feel right now
and then ask you to pick between those
two people a partner
for an anagram experiment that you're
about to do okay
so they're going to ask you by this is
sort of the this question what's the
difference or similarity between
what you say you're feeling is and what
you really do both things are important
but do they line up do they not line up
okay so let's here's here's the results
here's a graph and here's how this works
negative emotional distress the higher
the bar the more you say
i feel really bad about what's just
happened okay i just heard this comment
or no comment so let's take a look
higher the bar if you heard no comments
here's how you begin
um so let's start with the forecasters
you're for all of you are forecasters
because you're pretending you're in the
situation but you're not in it right
so here's there was no comment okay
that's sort of average or something and
then you said if you heard a racial slur
you would feel terrible
you would feel terrible
but look at the other students who are
randomly picked so it's not we don't
think it's a difference among students
look at these gray bars they're pretty
flat
okay the person on the spot
is somehow not processing this and
they're filling out i feel average
okay does that you see you see the split
the split between
the values of the person thinks they
would have and the values that are
responded to on the spot in the moment
and what we'll talk about later on in
social psychology is there's a tough gap
often between the values we espouse
and how we act when there's especially
unexpected difficult things okay and
very often
if you've had any experience like this
afterwards you go oh what i should have
done is this or i wish i would have said
that but that moment pat is not you know
happening at that moment probably
because you're kind of weirded out by
the whole thing like what's going on why
would the person say this this is you
know something doesn't seem right i
can't kind of sort it out and so people
tend to shrink
uh in terms of making a strong
conclusion of what's going on if
something seems unusually provocative
and you could say okay that's their
attitudes but how about their action who
do they pick to be their partner and
again
the people forecasting said if i was in
this situation
i would never pick
i would never pick that racist white
person to be my partner okay because
that person stinks
okay if i was in that situation but if
the people are in the situation
look at the gray bars
pretty flat
it's as if on the spot in the moment
they can't quite process the values they
feel and the action they're going to
take and we'll talk about that and it's
very hard often in part to be brave and
stand up to things it turns out there's
a lot of evidence for this it's a human
nature thing
it's very hard to be brave and stand up
to things when things are kind of weird
because almost every the first things
like i don't want to make a fool of
myself i don't want to make trouble you
know maybe i'm not getting the whole
picture on this and we shrink back from
acting in a way that aligns with the
values
that are clearly shown here
okay
so this this again is something about
human nature that's very weird and it's
so powerful we come into social
psychology and that's why it's very hard
to stand up to things like oppression
and bias it's very hard to do because we
tend to and not act on our values when
we're in complicated situations on the
spot
and there's a tremendous amount of
evidence for that
so again how we interpret this situation
very different in our mind when we
imagine we're there
and when we actually sit there and so so
what these researchers says this is
partly why it's been hard to sort of
eradicate some vestiges of stereotypes
and racism because people have a hard
time clamping down on it in the moment
so
so that's a tough topic but you know we
want to deal both with uh things that
are
are less controversial but also things
that touch people's lives in the real
world that we live in so we talked about
the scientific study of the human nature
mind and behavior how what we
see and hear
is determined so much by how our mind
interprets the world around us how we
remember things like word lists or
stories is hugely influenced by what we
expect to see like in the picture
how we think we know things like where
reno is compared to san francisco how we
think about things like the probability
that we'll have somebody else we'll have
the same birthday that somebody else
will in the group
and the relationship between how we feel
and how we act
the very feelings we have are often
disconnected for actions in the moment
uh and then sometimes that has a sort of
a difficult consequence and so we'll
explore all these things through this
semester all the different facets that
we can possibly get through one semester
of what it is to be a human and where
science has showed us something about
human nature the mind and the brain